the next talk is by Juan Luis Cano a
fine our space engineer almost almost
not yet I was playing that anymore we'll
have a will have a long talk during the
lunch yeah too much fight anything and
you will talk maybe some of you have
suffered the packaging problems in
Python it's a difficult topic and one
lewis oil try to explain how to solve
that if ganda so give a warm applause 21
Lewis thank you well thank you very much
thank you all of you for coming thank
you for the organization and for the
wine tasting yesterday for the speakers
because it was great lots of fun so the
title of my talk is the build system we
always needed but never deserved I even
know how to phrase this because it's
very easy you know to start saying that
everything is brocade and nothing works
and now nobody knows how to do this job
but the reality is that many people have
put a lot of hours of the spare time in
build these systems even if some of them
don't work very properly so I'm trying
to not be into this message not to
negative don't take any of what I'm
going to say at the beginning too
personal but I'm trying to also to make
it a bit of fun of the current situation
because I think that it's desertion so
let's begin with it I'm going to outline
a very a little bit and while we're
going to talk about first of all I'm
going to talk about the motivation what
brought us here why are we in need of
using Conda and Conda packages and then
we're going to outline how can we build
our first condom packet a very simple
one with just Python and then give some
a couple of more advanced tricks on how
can we use another languages make the
packets more useful for different
platforms and stuff like that and then
I'm going to talk about very briefly
about the new community effort that
Christine already
in hatak which is Conda fort and I'm
going to also talk about the limitation
of Conda because everything is benefit
there's no silver bullet as you already
know so I think it's fair to say a
couple of quakes that still exist before
we can work perfectly with this system
and then I'm jump into the conclusions
on finishing the talk and I don't know
if the transition is going to allow me
for a couple of minutes to talk about
the pike on in Spain that is coming at
the end of the year but anyway we'll
talk about it later because I'm not
going to speak for too long I hope well
this is me this stupid guy doing silly
things somewhere I'm an almost aerospace
engineer a student at polytechnical
Madrid I used to work at DMB which is a
sponsor of the other conference but now
i work at in descent which is a software
company working for 44 bva which is also
an sponsor and now i work with lots of
Python while before that I was working
more with fortune and stuff like that
and I usually write at x 180 which is a
blog in Spanish language about
scientific computing for now with Python
and I also the chair and will been able
to be later for life the Python Spain
non-profit Association and I'm also a
co-creator with my friend Alex of the
arrow Python group which is not related
to the alluring of all records in the
University of Washington bodies some
initiative what we've been carrying on
to teach aerospace engineers to use open
tools and especially Python and when
time permits which is rare I also write
some open source Python code especially
have a personal project which involves
interpenetrate Electress well I think
giving talks about scientific Python for
about three years already and I always
write this almost big thing of the I've
been an almost our space engineer for
quite a few years already
and it's not a funny situation
especially with my parents but you might
wonder what I've been doing for these
for these years and now i'm going to
splain some of it but it boils down to
fighting with compilers okay so what
brought us here which I also wanted to
call the sad state of scientific
software you might already know that the
scientific Python community has had many
problems with the packet in ecosystem
and in fact I thing is that combining
see extinctions and fortune instances
with Python code is not it used to be
very difficult and almost impossible to
make work on windows for instance and
actually in a 2014 conference with one
person told the scientific Python
developers to fix the problems
themselves because there was not much
interest in the core Python community so
yet for many years the windows packet is
made by Christophe goal we I'm sure many
of you already know where the only way
to install Python on on a Windows
machine before anaconda another Python
distributions can and do you does
anybody know the sage project here okay
some of you well for those of you who
don't know Safety's it's a Python
project that involves a lot of
mathematical libraries that mixes a lot
of open source project to develop an
alternative to matlab Mathematica that
is the philosophy of the period and
right now the situation is that they
they just ship the whole dependency Cena
in a big blob which is several gigabytes
in size and well needless to say that
it's impossible to make it work in
windows that the different versions you
have to in very specific ones to make it
work and actually they started as a
company providing such as a service to
free the people from this stunning
problems and actually this is not only a
problem in the
you know the scientific compiled well
because well how many of you write
Python for a living or for fun or
whatever okay how many of you can write
a set up I without looking on
stackoverflow ok it's very difficult
right and it's not only the compiled
packages as I told but also the
distributing Python the race is quite
difficult one package that you may not
know which is a bit more specific which
is bitsy it's a set of tools and the to
solve partial differential equations
well right now they also depend on many
third-party libraries but many of these
libraries don't have an open repository
for instance or they receive patches and
with open bugs or memory problems or
whatever and they don't fix them so they
D bitsy guys are forced to ship their
own forks of these third-party versions
because the upstream Athena's refuse to
to make the work so well this kind of
situation has made me fight for many
months to to carry my final my final
university project which in the end it
boils down to try to compile all these
things in a more or less portal way and
it specifically i'm using the dolphin
library which is also library intended
to solve partial division revisions for
with the philly tellement method which
has all these problems because it
depends on pet sea and many other
different packages so at some point I
was like this please make it stop and
these are the reasons because that
brought us here that portability is hard
unless you stick to pure python and that
properly distributing software libraries
is very hard because if you want to do
it right you have to take into account
many operating systems you have to take
into account that not everything is
enroute locations so this tends to
create a lot of problems unless your
ship some eternities which i will
mention right
the result is that we just think that if
it works in my machine then it's right
but it's not because this is not only a
matter of producing search results or
developing some application and when we
are talking about science for instance
it's also a matter of trying to justify
our results and allowing our peers to
reproduce our results and it's not very
clear for instance that ship in a
virtual machine or a container is the
solution for allowing our piece to the
producer results because as Peter Brown
said in the article that I link here yet
because you can provide a better manner
of eternal machine doesn't mean that
anyone other than you can install your
software so instead of just shipping
yourself what to ship a big container
around it to allow other people to work
on it and actually there are other
communities that are filling these
problems too and in particular this
article about if from if sorry which is
very well-known developer in the Python
web development community already
highlighted that if you have any
dependency which is in a compiled
language and you want to instil it in a
different location that is not the one
by default then basically your fault
because nobody provides the decorator
scripts to build this in a proper way so
what are the alternatives where I'm
going to talk about Conda be okay so
let's install it first and as you can
see here you can instead it by Conda and
that's it and the thing is that condo
packages is just a binary format the it
worked with the Condor package manager
and to begin with we can create a very
basic package starting with one that is
already available on PI P and this is
one of the first things that I wanted to
highlight because Conda is not directly
compatible with the by P packages so you
have to make a conversion in the in the
middle that i am going to
here and you seen using the contact
skeleton which is this common over here
you can translate these PI P packages
and it's going to produce a condor
recipe and what second the recipe
basically it's made of these three files
over here which is the most basic form
of a condo recipe and it's just a file
which contains all the metadata for
creating the packages and also a couple
of scripts for unix-like systems and
windows to actually install the our
software in particular the meta yeah Mel
it contains all the metadata in a
declarative form of the package and this
is a very important distinction from
what we're used to when we write for
example a setup I because we have the
function set up we where we declare some
descriptions i met a little inadequate
in form but the rest of the set up top i
can contain any logic because it's just
a python module and this tends to create
very complex installation processes and
in the end everybody makes their own
process so it's not very clear what's
the good way to proceed so here in this
way and you can declare some some
sections like where is your back to come
from what's the name duration what are
the requirements in install time and in
build time which is very very important
also some tests I will talk a bit later
of what's the process to build a condom
packet and wealth and description and
information about the license and stuff
like that so this is more or less how
method of jamel looks like I took the
pie this vent back pocket with this
which is a pure python package which was
not available on the official conduct
channels when I in prepared these lights
an hour ago so i just made with Condor
skeleton corner pocket and from the
package that you can find on piping and
yet here you can find the name the
version some dependencies which are not
a lot
and on the other hand you have the build
scripts which in this case just boil
down to python set up the pie instant
and that's it this is the way in which
you would install the software you were
in a show or something like that the
thing is that one for Windows it's
exactly the same thing the thing is that
countable when it's creating the package
it first downloads all the sources then
apply the patches if we specified any
then install the bill dependencies in a
separate Conda environment and then runs
the build spread at the same way the
same way in which we will do from the
shell packet is the new files and then
tests all the tests that we shipped with
the package with there so that indirect
help so this looks like a very legit
process on how to prepare a package
right because first you do you want to
isolate how you are building it a second
it's important also to test it just to
make sure before you are shipping that
all your tests run like we already do
this with other tools like we use stocks
or we use continuous integration or
whatever but here the whole process of
building the packet takes into account
all these steps and I think that is very
positive so in the end if you do
countable pie test bank park and you
specify here the Python version but in
this case is not very important well it
just runs these steps that I told you
before and at the end we have a tire
which is just a package with the
internal binary format the condom
allottees and well it has an amine
convention which takes into account the
Python version the version of the
package the build number which is also
important because contrary to what PI P
does for instance here you can take into
account that you have one version of the
packets but you might need to build it
in the future because there were some
problems with the back
you know stuff like that and the thing
is that right after you build the packet
you can use Conda install using this
flag use local here to install that
package that you just build so as you
can see this is a very let's say simple
way to translate a package that is
available on pypy any any package would
work and then having it available on on
Conda so it's a way to have it available
in a quick way before the it's available
in a different channel in the official
channels or whatever this conduct
skeleton thing that we did in the
beginning that face crease the resale
mostly works like I would say the words
with IT / eighty percent of the simple
Python packages but I don't think it
works with all of them and sometimes you
need to make some tweaks to the
resulting files but most of it it's
working well and now that we have this
process to build and create the packages
then there is also anaconda cloud which
is a repository analogous to pipe a to
upload all these packages that we are
creating in this case i'm i'm showing a
screenshot of my own profile in anaconda
club and you can see that i have a quite
a few packages uploaded there and not
only we can build this packet is locally
but also we have continuous integration
service provided by the Anaconda fox 2
which serves as a way to upload the
package tests and make all the tests and
automatically if we if we decide to do
so to upload the packet to our condo
channels and when you finish doing this
well i'm uninstalling the deep pockets
that is installed locally to try um I
know showing before that I'm to upload
the bucket is 21 icon the cloud but you
have to install the Anaconda client and
you just specify the name of the package
I don't think you can see the whole
common here
but anyway are you have to specify their
the the whole path and also optionally
what you should have you unloading too
and stuff like that and then when you
finish that well I as I told you before
I was removing the package that I
they're installed previously and now
specifying the channel which in this
case is the money account name then you
can install the package in me athlete
Nora you but anybody that you can turn
about okay so this is the very basics or
how to build a condom packet but here
there are some more advanced tricks that
we can use to build some more complex
packages and in particular to run the
tests we can provide a any combination
of these fight we can provide a Python
script a shell script even a perl script
as I can see there and actually this is
not limited as you can imagine to python
tests because here i'm taking a run test
script from a project that i'm working
on and actually here you can say that
I'm building some tests we see mate and
I just performing a make operation so as
you can see here this is not limited to
two Python and it is one of the big
advantages of Conda tool that you are
not limited to python packages also if
you are working only with Python the
good thing is that you are not worried
anymore about cross-platform issues
Portability and stuff like that so you
can use Condor convert to upload
packages for all the operative systems
and in particular if you you perform
this command over here and it specifies
specify that you want to convert to all
the platforms then you can upload the
spy test bench mark Condor package
available for all the operating systems
that are currently supported by anaconda
I'm going a bit fast I think I'll have a
lot of time for questions when I also
you can specify some platform specific
data in this case using some form of tax
in the channel file for instance um
taking some meta gem from viewers C or
C++ packets and you can see that for
instance if you want to make this
package work on Windows then you have to
provide in some way the visuals to your
runtime and stuff like that and as the
Python versions are compiled each one
with a different visual studio compiler
then here you can choose which
environment are you shipping with each
of depressions and of course you can
also say okay for linux and OSX for
instance i want to ship an additional
library which is only necessary in these
platforms and only you can do this but
also this metadata files support
templating youth using Ginja too so for
instance you can take the version number
from a continuous integration service or
you can use environment variables to
some kind of logic inside of the
metadata and stuff like that so this
allows for a lot of possibilities when
when trying to take into account all the
possibilities to to build the package
when one very special bit that I want to
highlight is that working with other
languages in principle is no different
that working with Python and in fact we
can even use it as a as a cross-platform
package manager there are already will
every linux distribution ships with
their own package manager also there are
some attempts to do that on Windows that
are going very well but as you are not
limited to python with Conda and
actually now they're using it to ship
GCC and many see core libraries and
stuff like that then you can use it to
distribute packages in all the platforms
the the only thing that we have to take
into account is that we don't need to
specify Python as a real dependency
apart from that it's not different also
they are using it to ship some our
packages
for instance here is the build script
for another packages that have been
mentioning before and as you can see
there is no no Python here and for
instance there's another possibility
that you can use a Python distutils to
compile assy assy extension instead of
using a make file for instance but then
in this case you what do you just need
to specify this Python of as a build
dependency but not a run dependency this
sounds very easy but in the end is not
because all the burden is in you and
what I mean here is that condo bill it's
not a tool meant to solve all our
problems and in particular it does not
solve for instance cross-compiling so if
you want to provide compiled packages in
Linux Windows and Mac you have to
compile it yourself in each of the
platforms on the other hand this is not
only a matter of cross and operative
system compatibility but also cross
linux compatibility because we already
know that the situation in the linux
world is a bit chaotic to a bit messy
and actually there are many sources of
incompatibility among linux
distributions the good thing is that i
will mention at the end of talk that
this this sources of incompatibility are
very well identified so if we take the
necessary precautions when building the
condo packet we can more or less get
along in particular building a clean
operating system like using a continuous
integration service or something like
that it's very important because we tend
to have a lot of system libraries
install with the system package manager
and they disturb the build the build
process because something that managed
to compile in one computer for instance
if it uses dynamic linking which is the
a case for for most of the packages that
is not possible anymore to run in a
different linux distribution which
doesn't have these these libraries and
again the good thing is that in
principle the decor libraries of Lindos
have a very strict backwards
compatibility policies so for instance
if you managed to compile any packet in
a very old linux distribution with like
centos-5 or a very old like open to 10
or something then more or less its
guarantee that it will work in in all
future versions and also there's there
are other problems that also fall in the
land of the packets themselves because
sometimes the build process or the
process of looking for the libraries is
not very smart and for example I've
found in the past a lot of packages that
hard code all the paths or some of the
path of the libraries that they need and
these cases the build will for sure fail
because as Conda is creating a new
environment to make all the compilation
process if this assumes that you have to
find some library in the root locations
then it's not going to work and actually
not only is not going to work in your
computer but also if you try to make
that packet work in another system this
is not going to work either because it's
not going to find the library so this is
a source of problems that you have to
either tune very carefully the
completion options or just patch the
package and inform the maintainer in
general the advice from the slightest
that is the recital if the recipe builds
in a clean headless because the
graphical library is also the store a
little bit the process and are quite old
names distribution then it's going to
build everywhere but there's this have
the we have to take some care with this
process well and this is all about how
to build the Condor packages and now I'm
not to mention very briefly the condo
forge you see that Christine already
and talked about in her talk as you know
this one authoritative resource of condo
packages which is a continuum that they
have the official channels and also as I
explained before you can create your own
channels but for instance for the core
packages most of the recipes are not
public so you don't know for instance
how do they build numpy or how to
rebuild matalie some very core packages
and in general having a community
initiative in this respect is very
important because then well it's very
easy to control the tools that the
continuing gave us in this case because
they are license with a very permissive
license without any burden but yet at
some point we have to take care of the
process and in particular this kind of
alternative is very is very powerful
because they are combining the Condor
packages with many free continuous
integration services that work in
windows linux and OSX so in the end the
process looks like you upload a condo
recipe which is as any canal recipe that
you can find anywhere and the system
automatically a correct some some quirks
and builds it in many continuous
integration services and if everything
is fine then it's uploaded automatically
in the condo fort anaconda channel so
it's very very useful to have all these
community packages uploaded in one
central channel because one of the
limitations that I will mention after
that and in general it's very good to
ensure that your packaging runs
everywhere well and if you decide not to
if you transfer if you do not support
windows or something then it also shows
in the bill Maddox that your pockets
does not run on
windows and they also have the very high
quality standard so it's an easily worth
checking um and this is the approaching
the end of the talk I wanted to talk
about some limitations that I found
while working with Condor build these
are very young tools because Condor for
instance i think it was released in 2012
may be more or less and Conda build I
saw the first article in the continuing
blog in 2013 so you think about that you
it's only been three or four years see
we've been having this and they still
have some problems but they are working
on it but they can be a pardon to work
on some things specifically specifically
there are already shipping questions of
the day of the c compiler the new
compilers and the lead gfortran for
instance but they're having many
compatibility issues because of the
versions and because it's not easy
apparently to ship portable build of the
GCC so right now it's it's mostly
working but again it's giving some
problems then do if you download the
slides which already updating it have to
confine some links some links the other
thing is that in the meta file where you
specify all the dependencies there is no
way to say okay this dependency is going
to be in this channel and that is a
problem because in the end it makes you
how to upload all your dependencies
either wait for the continuing guys to
upload them to the official channels or
upload them to your own channel and this
can be a burden to this is why having
this counterfeit channel is very good
because you have one channel with all
the community packages build and also
i'm providing a link to hear pinning the
numpy a version is very special and can
be a bit messy because numpy defines a
lot of properties of the behavior of the
packages and
it's taken in a particular case and from
my point of view it's still not
something very very clearly and not very
well documented so obese this feature is
likely to evolve in the future and also
I've been talking all the time about the
dick Conda packages but as you already
know there are many initiatives in the
Cure decor Python community to provide
waves to distribute packages and stuff
like that in the past they were not very
useful to solve the problems that we had
a scientific community but they are
making very good progress in recent
years specifically ah well pip already
catches wills locally so for instance
what tends to happen when I started
developing in Python is that every
single time that I pip install numpy it
compiles on my system and I got sick of
that and that's why I'm using Conda
since the very beginning but now this
does not happen anymore because you
compile it once or you download our will
and that's it the other thing is that
windows and OSX and wheels are already
very very popular and everybody is
distributing them so there is no problem
there and finally do you remember that
you cannot upload Linux wheels on pypy
because it's not clear if they're going
to work on all the distributions and so
on as we've been already talking about
and now they found a way to okay it so
late some of the causes that might make
these packages not work very well across
linux distributions and now they created
the many linux I don't know if I
mentioned it here well this paper over
here defines at the many linux tag which
is some kind of a process to provide a
will that works in many linux
distributions taking some some special
care and as a last bit of information
they are also trying to get rid of this
digital set of tools mess that is been
jerking us off or soul
and they're trying to decouple the build
system from the installation system so
they are making slow progress because
they have to reach the agreement of the
whole community and it's normal that is
lower but they're making good progress
and I think there will be some changes
in the future maybe when we dropped
Python 2 who knows still there are some
quicks for instance the PIP doesn't have
a dependency solver so you can end up
with a lot of funny situations in condo
build for me has a more streamlined
process of building the package then
testing then uploading in everything in
a single tool so for me it's more useful
in the end follow my advice and keep
calm and condensed and that's it you can
find these lights on github already and
you can find my profile here you can
find me on Twitter or on many accounts
on Twitter because I handle too many
already and please approach me during
the conference even if you don't know me
please don't be shy to say me hello
please talk me speak to me about your
project your ideas I will be glad to to
share into to know about what you are
doing and that's it thank you very much
questions I have a question how do you
think that Conda needs to be an
alternative to any other packaging
system that now everyone's using I mean
set of tools I mean there's something it
isn't well the thing is that college is
not really an alternative and that's not
intend to be because in the M as you all
saw you are using set up top I instant
so you are relying on the underlying
implementation of the installation
script they are actually more like a way
to provide simple binary packages and a
way to automate a bit the process that's
that's what I mean I mean build on top
of something that is kind of broken yeah
well the thing is that they are relying
in some way on the core Python community
to fix those problems but in principle
if they for example if they maintain all
the AP is and they separate beep and the
students for instance without breaking
too much things in principle is going to
work but yes right now it's like a layer
on top of something that is broken that
works
so is there any way to specify a series
of packages version to build the same
package for a term for it embraces of
moon pie or side pie because what am I
you stocks for to peel the person of an
open source packets to support different
different numba version different
secular version so pleased with condo
voices yeah exactly I think it was
briefly showcased in one of these lights
when you when you are doing the Condor
build step yeah I'm getting there yes
there you specify the Python version so
you can specify not only the Python
questions you can use 3534 and stuff but
also specify the non privation and
actually if you specify the number
evasion it's also highlighted there in
the name of the package I don't know if
it answers your question more questions
we still have time for questions ok
there are no questions let's thank one
do it again